みなさんこんにちわよろしくお願いします
今日は皆さんに3人の子供たちを紹介したいと思います
1人目ですが私が大学生の時であった
中学2年生の女の子です彼女は
学校に行ってみんなと一緒に燕京することができません
いわゆる不登校の生徒です
今年度の文科省の投稿に関する調べによると
全国の9万7000人の中学生が
不登校だそうです
つまり36人に一人の割合で不登校の生徒がいるということになります
推定のお子さんです
美穂さんは脳性麻痺による四肢体幹機能障害があります
また重度知的障害があり
日常生活のほとんどで会場必要とします
彼女のできないことに注目すると
このようにたくさんのできないことが積み重なっていく状況です
最後に3人目のお子さんを紹介します
ひろゆきさんは
広汎性発達障害と
精神障害があります
強迫性神経障害という精神疾患があります
彼は予期せぬことが起こるとパニックになってしまうため一人で外出することができ
ません
また映画をでこんにちはと目と目を合わせて挨拶することができません
歌詞多くの方は彼を見たとき彼が障害があるとは気付かないと思います
なぜなら彼は普通に歩くことができるし会話もすることができるからです
彼のことを理解できない
人たちは彼に愛さつ一つできないなんてと声をかけたり一人で外泊外出できないなんて
甘ったれてる
努力が足りないと彼にい続けました
彼が中学2年生のときに書いた文の中でこのような表現がありました
皆さんは今を紹介した3人の子供たち
またその家族が抱える一番の障害はなんだと思うでしょうか
少しイメージしてください
私は
彼らやその家族が抱える一番の障害というのは健常者だと思い込んでいる
私たち一人一人が持っている無理解や偏見が作り出す
障害っていうのが一番の障害になっているのではないかと感じます
つまり障害がある人の生きにくさというのは私
たちが作り出しているのです
皆さんは視覚障害者と聞いたときどのような人をイメージするでしょうか
たぶん多くの方が目が見えない人という形をイメージしたのではないでしょうか
では聴覚障害者
深海障害者と聞いたとききっと皆さん耳が聞こえない人歩けない人という形をイメージ
したのではないかと思います
つまり私たちは障害という言葉を聞くと
何がにができない人ということで障害を捉えているのです
そして
健常者だと思い込んでいる私たちは障害がある人に対して
その生涯を消すように
しいることが多々あります
例えば私たち風邪を引いた時
医者に行って薬をもらって直すことができます
例えば5節を者と武器
それも同様で手術をしたりリハビリをして一時は神対象会社と同じような状況になって
も
一時は神対象箇所が同じような状況になってもまた
直すことができますでも今障害と言われている障害者と言われている人たちの生涯は今
の医学では決して直すことができません
にもかかわらず私たちは
障害者に健常者と同じ視点で生活レベルや基準を押し付けることが多々あります
学校でも同じようなことが起きているのではないかと感じることがおります
具体的には子どもたちのできないところに目を向けて何とか健常者のレベルに近づけて
いこう
障害による困難さを改善克服していこうという視点で深夜指導を行っているケースが
非常に多いのではないかと感じています
の小中学校でも同様だと思います
学習障害というのがいま話題に上っていますが読むことができないこう書くことができ
ない子
計算をすることができない子どもたちがいますどんなに頑張ったってそこは障害なので
改善克服するということは非常に難しいのです
例えば計算できない子リシキはできるのに
ます
計算ができないためにテストで0点をとってしまいます
そのような子どもに計算機を渡せば
意識ができてるからテストで100点をとることができるのにそれはダメと言われて
いる
お子さんが非常に多いそうです理由としてはみんなは計算機使わなくても計算している
からいっぱい計算燃焼性はできるんじゃないかという指定を持っている先生も非常に
多いというのが現状だそうです
そのような教育を受け自分に自信がない子どもたち
また物事に積極的に働きかけようとしない子供
自分なんかダメな人間なんだと思っている子どもが非常に多くいるのを感じています
また保護者も同様で
自分の子供に希望が見いだせない親
先生
私自分の子どもと一度死のうと思ったんです
初めて私保護者からその言葉を聞いたとき非常にショックでした
のままでいいのかなと
感じています
話は変わりますが皆さんサヴァン症候群という方をご存知悪化さバージョン候群という
言葉をご存知でしょうか
生涯をもガール人の中には驚異的な記憶力を持ちその力を音楽や美術などさまざまな
分野で発揮する人たちがいます
こちらの作品は一度見た気に入ったチラシを完璧に暗記し
再現することができる立った小学1年生の男の子の作品です
このように誰が見てもこの子の才能は長けていると分かるような鯖の子供たちが実際に
どのような教育を受けているのか気になり2011年に長野県内の3校の特別支援学校
でアンケート調査を行いました
10年以上特別支援学校に勤めている
教員のうち約半数以上がサヴァン症候群の児童生徒の支援に携わっていることが分かり
ました
っっしかし
そのすぐいた力やその才能を伸ばすための支援を
学校内もしくは学校外で
受けていた生徒というのはたった13%でした
その優れた力を就職に活かしたケースというのはひとりもいませんでした
ではなぜ
彼らの優れた力を伸ばすような支援を行わなかったのかという質問に対し
一番多かった答えが障害によるコーナーさの改善克服が一番大事であるから中には優れ
た力を伸ばしても意味がないと回答した
先生も腹水ました
ああああああ
本当に優れた力を認め伸ばすということが意味がないのでしょうか
私は本当にそこが非常に疑問に思ったので
冒頭でご説明した3人の子供たちに彼らの優れた力や得意なところを伸ばすための支援
を行いました
ぜひ皆さん3人のお子さんたちの事例をみて本当に優れた力や得意なところを伸ばす
ことに意味がないのかどうかぜひ考えてみてください
1人目の不登校の a さんですが
皆さんもし家族にまた自分の娘や息子
兄弟で兄弟が不登校になってしまったらどのようにどのように声を掛けるですか国家つ
いますどういうふうに声をかけますか
彼女は学校に行くんだったら死んだ方がましだと言っていました
彼女に私は
このように声をかけました
そして
夢について聞きましたすると将来漫画家になりたいという夢を教えてくれました
そのため私は家庭教師として彼女の支援に関わることになったのですが
彼女の得意なへのサインを伸ばすことまた
ギターが
興味があると言っていたのでギターの指導もしました
きっと皆さん家庭教師というと
勉強を教えるものだと思っている方も多いかと思うのですが私はあえてその2点をまず
教えました
すると彼女は
その力が伸びただけなくだんだんと学習に対して意欲的になりなんと高校受験を頑張り
ました
高校受験に合格し高校に入ったら毎日学校に通えるようになったそうです
そして生徒会にも入り成績は毎年1以下兄のトップクラスでした
非常に充実した高校生活を送ったそうです
そして周りの先生方から有名な大学を勧められても全部決定
漫画家になるための専門学校に現在通っています
こちらの作品をご覧下さい
こちらはの先日私の結婚式のために彼女が書いてくれた作品です
現在彼女は複数の出版社のショー樹脂受賞し
なんと担当の編集者の方も月
これからマンガ家になるためのデビューに向けて準備を始めているそうです
続いて
miho さんです
みのさんは冒頭にもお伝えした通り脳性麻痺による四肢体幹機能障害があるため日常
生活の多くの場面で支援を必要としています
本人も自分はできないっていうのもよくわかっていて自分から積極的に物事に手を出し
て働きかけたりまた特にあの
絵を描くってのは非常に大嫌いなお子さんでした
彼女はテレビが非常に
好きで私が持っている ipad に非常に興味を示していたためその ipad を
学習の中に取り入れることにしました
すると今まで
見せなかったこのような姿を見せてくれました
ご覧ください
浜ございました言葉も共に
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo
dj
ビクター
は始まらない
today
このように積極的に画面に働きかけて手を動かす様子が見られるようになってきました
あれほど体を持って書くと張ってペンを話して書かなかったお子さんがなんと自分から
お世話になった理学療法士の先生に手紙を書きたいと言って自らペンを持っていかいた
時の初めての時の様子です
いい
いいですか
もうおしまいにしますまだ書きたいなのか期待よろ少し書きました
ん
違う色にしますか
はい
えちょうだいっ
このようにいろんな色を使ってもうお姉妹するのってとまだ書きたいといって何度も
ぐるぐる書いて
医学療法しょん先生に餌をと届けることができました
その後も澪さんの様子ですがなんとその日を境に毎日絵を描くようになり親や周りの
先生
また友達にへ送るようになりました
さらに今まで手を動かすことが難しかったのですがだんだんとてが動かせるようになっ
たことでお買い物学習で好きなお菓子を選んだり
またカードを選択できるようになり
カードや言葉の学習を進めていくことができるようになりました
最後に裕之さんです
優木さんは幼い頃から絵を書いていました
また
ギターや英語にも興味を持っていたため
立った毎日5分間だけですが毎日それらを伸ばすための指導を行いました
すると
1年後には
私以外の先生方も彼の力を伸ばすための支援に携わってくれるようになりました
この写真を
ギターを使ってマックや ipad で作曲をしている様子です
その後彼は一人では外出することが難しかったのになんとギター教室と英会話教室に
通うことができるようになりました
そしてこのようにバンド演奏をしたりまた英検にもチャレンジし呼吸4級を取得し
そしてついおととい
連絡が来たのですが
英検3級の一次試験を突破したそうです
今は2次試験に向けて頑張っています
こちらが先月の様子です
なんと一人では怖くて外出できなかった子が
ギター教室や英会話教室に一人で通えるようになりたいと自分で言ってなんと自分で
電車に乗って
いた教室や a か英会話教室に通う姿です
優れた力を認めて伸ばしたことによって子どもたちがその力が伸びただけでなく今まで
苦手だったこともできるようになってきました
もう一度聴きたいと思います本当に優れた力を認め
伸ばす事っていうのは意味がないことでしょうか
7さ vans プロジェクトというプロジェクト信州大学准教授のあり事件史先生と
取り組み始めました
このプロジェクトでは生きにくさやこんなアンサーを抱える人たちの優れた力
また得意な力を認め伸ばしていく
またその場を提供する力を発揮する場を提供することを通じて
人々の渉外官というものを変えることを狙いとしています
周りの人たちが子供たちの優れた力に着目し
伸ばしたことによってこんなにも子どもたちが変化しました
もしあなたが
もしここにいる皆さんがあたしゃ会の皆さんが
小健常者という
概念を捨てて
人々のできるところや得意なところを生かす視点っていうのを持つことができたら
今まで障害者とされていた方が障害者ではなくなるのではないかと感じています
あなたが変わることによってまわりの人を変えていくことができます
それがどんどんどんどん繰り返されて
周りの人社会そして世界が海底世界が変わっていくのだと感じています
今日私の話を聞いて
パートの渉外官が少しでも変わって初めてこの7鯖ずプロジェクトというのはスタート
しますご静聴ありがとうございました